are you being sarcastic about them
selling the team because that is one of
the kind no i think
no i think they're i think they're going
to i think they want to uh the arlington
heights thing which came out yesterday
they're trying to you know they're put
in a bid to buy arlington heights which
for people who aren't familiar is about
30 miles outside of where or 30 miles
from where soldier field is 45 minute
drive
it's a a huge spot where they can put a
stadium where they can build something
around it make it state of the art the
bears have a bad stadium situation it's
the smallest in the entire nfl
which is which is just like crazy
because the chicago is the biggest city
without two teams
uh
it's outdated they renovated it 20 years
ago it's already outdated it looks
beautiful but the park district owns it
so the bears don't even own their own
stadium so i think this is a two-part
move mike they basically are saying hey
we want you to add more seats to soldier
field renovate it again or
we're going to bid on arlington we're
going to we're going to buy the land
and then guess what someone who wants to
come buy the bears if we had already
purchased the the land uh we could be
the most valuable franchise in the nfl
because you'd have a state-of-the-art
stadium you'd own it all these things so
i you know i i would not be shocked if
if the mccaskeys
sell in the next five years i know that
we've been saying it for a while but
they are unlike any other setup in the
nfl right now where it's a mom and pop
shop it's not the mccaskeys have money
because they had a big you know uh
billion dollar corporation before the
bears the bears are their money so
if you're gonna split up the pie and you
have like a bunch of grandkids and great
grandkids you got to sell it to split up
the pie so i think that's going to
happen eventually i really do well and
here's the problem i don't want to get
too far down the legal rabbit hole after
all great guy terrible lawyer but the
estate taxes will become an issue how
have they set this up
so that when virginia passes
they're able to pay the estate tax bill
and still have enough cash on hand to
operate the team sometimes what you got
to do is start selling off equity to pay
the estate tax and there have been
multiple sales over the years of nfl
franchises jack kent cook for example
had to sell the
uh who was the owner before wayne
heisinga joe robbie of the dolphins
family had to sell they had to sell to
pay the estate taxes there's concern
when
al davis widow passes they're going to
have to sell the raiders to pay the
estate taxes that's going to be an issue
for these families that don't have
otherwise billions in the coffers and
and and you know you may be onto
something here
the the yeah right the the arlington
uh site
and this rumor you know that they might
sell the team has been going on forever
right but the arlington site
does give them a chip where if they were
to sell the team they could either say
well we have this and you can negotiate
with the city of chicago and figure out
a new stadium situation or we have this
and you can build your own stadium and
now the you know the the price
skyrockets because if the bears own
their own stadium it's a
state-of-the-art stadium you can have a
super bowl you can have a wrestlemania
you can have the final four you can have
the big ten championship game all these
events that chicago just gets passed
over for because it's you know soldier
field small and it's outdoors
i it changes the dynamic of what the
price tag is and how much money that the
mccaskey could potentially reap from
this sale
and let me say on behalf of the folks at
peacock since peacock exclusively
streams wrestlemania thank you for
listening wrestlemania before
the final four let me throw one more
curveball at you before we move on
because we have a fun little exercise
we're going to do to cap this segment is
chicago big enough to have two teams two
nfl teams i mean yes population wise
because you like i said it's the third
biggest city that it's the biggest city
in the nfl that doesn't have two teams
la in new york obviously have two teams
i i don't think would it work with two
teams i don't think so i do not think so
i do not think so i think it would be a
very hard sell just because it's steeped
in tradition and it would be a very very
hard sell in my mind
i i cause if they're if someone's going
to buy that team and build their own
it's the stan cronky model
you built the stadium
and then
you have a tenant another chicago team
and as as these other teams start
looking around for stadium situations
and they may be disgruntled dissatisfied
with theirs and they don't want to have
to pay all of it and they've tried to
find somebody to pay part of it i i've
been saying for a few years now that and
if there's expansion in the league which
i think is coming in the next five to
ten years they haven't talked about it
yet but i think they will
i think a second team in chicago makes
sense and if there's a state-of-the-art
stadium that holds 80 000 people and
it's you know 30 miles outside of town i
i i think that it's something to keep an
eye on
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports